the recruitment industry wasn't really
established we didn't really like
recruit we were just good at it and
making money and then at some point my
moral compass kicked in and I realized
some of the things that we were doing
weren't really cool we weren't looking
after people if your strength is
delivering if your strength is running
the best goddamn Boolean out there if
your strength is finding the best
candidates that's terrific but if you're
going to build a business if you're
going to build a community in a
Marketplace and a reputation and you
can't win business and you can't
maintain and build relationships with
the people that pay your bills then
don't do it
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast on this
week's episode I was joined by Mark long
this is one of the three co-founders
from a new recruitment business called
numi Mark has worked in recruitment for
over 25 years both Isabella manager team
lead and now business owner I absolutely
love Mark's mindset and the passion he
has for recruitment so in this
conversation we talk about Mark's career
the entrepreneurial journey and plenty
of the tactics and approaches that have
continued to work Hallmark over the
decades he's worked in the industry
enjoy the episode Mark welcome to the
podcast hey hm it's great to be here
thank you for making the trip really
appreciate it I've really enjoyed our
conversations leading up to this I'm
always curious to find out how people
have stayed so long in the recruitment
industry
sorry to lead to that right away but
you're someone that clearly absolutely
loves what you do you'll I know how
passionate you are about yeah raising
the bar and Recruitment and that really
resonates with me so I'm I'm really
excited to unpack this journey of yours
I guess before we get started
um always like to just add a bit of
context to
um your journey so everyone can just
understand where you're at where you've
been uh right away so feel free to add
anything to this that you think is
crucial that I've missed but I guess
initially you are in your fourth decade
of recruitment it's a long time that's a
long time right so yeah I've definitely
got questions around that I think today
uh what we're going to do is really hone
in and focus on this entrepreneurial
Journey that you've been on with your
two business partners in building your
own recruitment business called new me
over the last two and a bit years but
obviously before that
um you worked for a few different brands
and built a successful recruitment
career so we're absolutely going to
touch on that but I guess the the
context for what we're going to be
really focusing on today is
um knew me so just really quickly on
this and then we can get into this
further in the the podcast but numi um
started officially although it was
incorporated in November 2020 the First
full year was 2021 official launch of
the business was January 2021 yeah and
you started it with uh two business
partners nibs and Ricky yeah right nibs
hopefully has called me uh using that
right yeah he is um so uh yeah so first
year and it was just you free and we'll
get into this but I know the real Focus
was to build traction
um and yeah build start building the
business between you three so I know
first year revenue-wise you ended up on
around 1.6 million
um and that was your first year then we
have
um the second year so 2022 last year
um I know then you ended up going down
the the hiring route because you always
wanted to grow this business
um so correct me if I'm wrong but I do
believe is there so there's five
recruiters and there's two people in Ops
antenna acquisition yeah that's right
this is around seven seven of you at the
moment right and then um I know you were
gonna do some um fact checking on this
but I know you did share with me when
prep preparing for this but I think
Revenue suck around 2 million in 2022 or
is that completely wrong uh no the
actual Revenue in 2022 is 5 million okay
the total revenue the gross profit is
2.2 million well okay yeah so I've got
the the GP and the revenue wrong so
there we go so I think that will just
help a lot of people immediately
understand where you're at as a business
which is really exciting so I'm really
excited to dive into this so where we
always like to start is this million
pound question that I'm sure you and
your business partners have really had
to think long and hard about for your
own business
so I'd love to hear your take so in your
opinion what characteristics and traits
do you believe make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant in in
today's market yeah so you'll kill a
question
um we were just talking about you hiring
a salesperson yourself those three
things we we've distilled those down and
I'm going to go with uh number one being
intrinsic motivation you can always tell
when somebody's got a great desire
passion they kind of know their why they
know what they're doing and why they're
getting out of bed every morning and
it's really hard if you don't have that
because the life cycle of recruitment is
always changing
um so from year to year month to month
you can have highs and you can have lows
and you need to know what drives you
um so intrinsic motivation
second point I'd say is uh curiosity and
a thirst for learning
um just to reiterate again about
recruitment is always changing no two
days are the same and in your journey
you will go through the gears from a an
associate to a recruiter to a principal
then you might move into management or
leadership and so you've got to unpack
you know one of your favorite words what
those data points are that help you to
move forward in your journey that help
you to be the best version of you and
then thirdly I like to work with people
that are focused on the customer and
they're obsessive about doing the right
thing they see beyond the paycheck they
see beyond the next deal they will
always do the right thing and they see
the Hat the The Horizon of what is a
really great and excellent service so
people make themselves memorable they
build Relationships by
building companies and helping people in
their careers to move forward so you
have to be obsessive about customer
experience and I know that that's
definitely something you're you've been
obsessed and yeah you are obsessed with
which I sort of learned quite quickly
when speaking to you I guess to touch on
Mark the recruiter and I know that you
have had to be absolutely Hands-On from
the very beginning of of new me right um
to build traction and build business but
I guess there's you've been in the
industry for a while so I guess the
question I'd love to ask you is what
would you say are marks one to three key
principles
um when it comes to being great at
recruitment that you've obviously
learned all over this time like what are
some of the the key principles that you
live by each day that you live by uh
right now that you just learned along
the way that you feel
um really enables you to consistently
perform hit the goals that you set
yourself we'd love just to hear Mark's
perspective on yeah those those key
principles that you you live by and I'm
sure you sort of trying to instill in
people or share why they're your key
principles internally with your teams
yeah sure I mean it's been a while uh
when I when I think back to who I was
when I first began and first started my
journey in recruitment I think it was
just team and energy
um and follow-ups
um the first business I worked in in the
late 90s we had a system uh which was
driven by the um the technology that we
had at the time
um which was pretty much
um writing in a book
and a really really bad CRM but we had
to follow up with all of our candidates
so we I was a contract recruiter way way
way back and it was always about
following up with your candidates it was
about those three month extensions what
are you doing and it was about energy
and it was about kind of consistency so
it was always being really consistent
following up with your with your
Marketplace and being accountable to
your team
um those were the early traits that I
saw
um I think I think now what makes a
really great recruiter versus what makes
a good recruiter is always doing the
right thing whether that is on behalf of
your customer your your partner
portfolio whether that has been on
behalf of your candidate and really
listening to what your candidate is
looking to achieve in their life or
whether that is within your company
within your team or your stakeholders so
if you're always doing the right thing
by your customer
um then then and the people that work
with you then you're going to be a great
team member and you you're really going
to stand out and make a difference what
do you think are some of the factors
that uh
in uh what's the word I'd love to just
get your thoughts on that I that really
resonates with me but
because of the world that I'm in and we
um train recruiters and they they want
to build a successful career these
things sometimes it can be hard to do
the right thing for like different
factors it might be that you're working
with a really difficult client that
isn't quite seeing or understanding the
value that you can give to them and that
might encourage you to make some
short-term decisions that maybe longer
later down the line you regret or
whatever you might be an environment
where you have marked the the manager
who's really trying to encourage you to
take action hit your kpis these types of
things I'd love to get your perspective
because
um I really buy into that but I'd love
to get your thoughts on what do you
think can sometimes be the factors
um that can influence Recruiters in our
industry end up not doing the right
thing because it makes sense right do
the do the right thing by your customers
and these things and over time
um it will play out sometimes quickly
sometimes over the long term so I don't
know what what you think about that when
we think about factors that influence
the people not doing the right thing
and one of the most obvious factors is
is targets
um so you've got recruitment people that
have sales targets and if they're having
a bad quarter or they're having an
appraisal or a review with their manager
and they're behind Target
um they need to do deals otherwise
they're they're feeling Jeopardy they
feel that they might lose their job so
they start to make bad decisions they
start to then manipulate the system and
start to Showcase or spec CVS or submit
bad you know candidates that don't match
the brief to to the job of the customer
or they start to aggressively Hound the
customer to try the book in the
interviews to get the deal done
um that that's not the right way to do
the business that's not the right way to
build a sustainable career in
recruitment
um I think those are some of the reasons
why people have you know bad practices
uh in terms of in terms of recruitment
because they're possibly trying to keep
their job or you know there's possibly
some sort of competition going on and
they're trying to be the biggest biller
in the in the room
um I don't really like to see those and
and in those moments when I've had
conversations with people that are under
those pressures and strains the advice
and the encouragement that I always give
to them is that actually if you are
following the right steps if you are
being excellent in every single
measurement along the way if you're
doing what you're supposed to do over
the course of time that will come out
and over the course of time you will be
successful
I mean my dad always used to say to me
that he could do my job because it
sounds really easy it does sound really
easy right
um
but not consistently to do the job well
to do to do the job to a great and and
an excellent level consistently month
after month year after year there are no
flukes there are no shortcuts you just
have to be really great in every Point
yeah I love that so I'd be I'd be stupid
not to ask you this like how how has
Mark uh stayed in the industry for so
long and like you said that consistency
that's that's no fluke so I'd love to
just yeah delve into a mindset a bit
around like why you think you've been
able to just consistently show up
continue to to love the job most the
time I'm sure there's yeah really
difficult times and there's been
um hard times for you but
um yeah like this is I whenever we speak
to uh recruiters who have big goals in
the industry like you really will
achieve your goals or have the best
chance of achieving them if you're in it
for the long run like obviously most
careers right but obviously yeah you're
in your fourth decade of recruitment
like talk to us about why you think
think you've been able to just yeah
consistently show up year after year
you're still here I can tell how
passionate you are about it still like
how have you been able to do that
I think I'll probably break it down
maybe
um my first my first role right
individual contributor recruitment
company before the year 2000 let's call
it that
um and that was The Wolf of Wall Street
it was you know S3 kind of you know
aggressive recruiter Boiler House I
think there was probably
40 white blokes in an office trading and
it was just all or nothing
I found that I was really successful
um in the sense that I was making a lot
of money we were all killing it the
recruitment industry wasn't really
established but I definitely didn't love
recruitment it was it was just a vehicle
for me we used to laugh and joke in the
office that we didn't really like
recruitment we were just good at it and
making money
and then at some point my moral compass
kicked in and I realized some of the
things that we were doing weren't really
cool like we weren't looking after
people
um
and and that didn't resonate with me
um and so I left that business to join
um another firm which was a small
boutique business
um and I joined that business as a
director so I went from
no management really
um given a job title of a director even
though I had no reports um to build a
business and so for about 15 years I
felt like I was building business and
what I felt like in that drove me to
build a community to build relationships
um which is where I started doing the
right thing
um and and where I continued following
up and being consistent because
my name was on the door effectively I
knew that the long-term game here would
outplay
that immediate deal of that short-term
paycheck
um so this is where then my career
started to evolve we started to hire
people and I went through management and
Leadership and different different
positions that I occupied and I guess
that over the years I've I've fallen in
love with recruitment rather than being
in love with recruitment to start with
um I don't know if that answers your
question no it does what about
I speak to I'm sure you've interviewed
these people and you've you've helped
people on this journey but what what
sort of what sort of things does Mark do
to
yeah protect your your mindset I guess
because I love all those things that
you're saying but it's it's bloody
difficult right so I don't know some of
the the sort of habits you formed or
just things that you live by that you
think enable you to yeah get good at not
letting your emotions take over not
letting a candidate drop out or these
things that can happen in recruitment
ruin your entire day or make you think
what the hell am I doing in recruitment
why do I do this I don't know yeah I'd
love to just understand a bit more about
because I'm sure you've built habits
over time that you feel have just
enabled you to just stay on that middle
ground not get too high with the highs
not get too low with the lows like talk
to us a bit about that because I think
that would be really useful for for
people that yeah May struggle with that
yeah I guess so when I think back to
just being a straightforward biller
right
um and a deal drops out or a candidate
pulls out of an interview
um how can you stop thinking about that
how can you take a moment and breathe
um how can you continue your job go to
work the next day and not still will be
not smarting that you've lost that deal
that you thought you'd had
and it's really tough
I think what I used to do was
do my best to understand what went wrong
and what could I do to change that in
the future and if that was from my
initial screening with the candidate and
maybe I didn't ask the right questions
or I didn't document the right notes or
if it was from the initial screening
with the client where I didn't
understand what the brief was didn't pay
attention to some of the the fine
details around what the offer was going
to be then I would I would always look
to analyze and see what the gaps were
and see what I could learn from so then
I could rectify that and go again and
back on the horse and make sure I failed
that job when I was young when I was a
biller I was just so competitive I just
just ridiculously competitive and I just
wanted to make sure that I was being
successful there was a leaderboard and
and I wanted to be at the top of it so I
just sort of had that unwavering like
commitment competitive streak where I
just needed to be the best
and I didn't really want to let anything
get in my way
um now it's different I guess as I've
matured and aged
those individual deals don't really
affect me so much now because they
happen that's part and parcel of life
people change their minds
um
and so as I've aged I've started to be
more mindful so I manifest I practice
meditation I exercise a lot and I've got
strong anchor points that motivate me
which are principally around my my
family my friends my house practice
gratitude and those kind of techniques
have really helped me
um as I've kind of grown into myself
yeah I think that's the that's the great
thing that comes with experience right
you just just gather all the six this
evidence and these experiences to go yep
I've been here before this happened
before but I now know that that happened
and then this positive thing happened
right and sometimes at the beginning
when you don't have that evidence is
tough so I appreciate you sharing that
so let's talk about this entrepreneurial
Journey then um with new me and I guess
what the hell we've learned so far on
this journey obviously you're just over
two years in I guess what I'd love to
just hear your thoughts on initially
having
um done the job for a while and work for
different businesses like what was top
of mind
um with you and your business partners
when we're thinking about being
different
um speaks a lot of recruitment
entrepreneurs who always sort of say
that I wanted to start my business
because I think we could do it better I
think we could do it different so what
was your take on how can we make new me
different in the marketplace as as
you'll be aware is bloody competitive
there's so many recruitment companies in
in the UK so talk to us a bit about yeah
what was top of mind when we're thinking
how can we be different how can we stand
out what's our differentiates are
um when building our own recruitment
business in in new me let's start there
yeah
so that the journey starts before numi
um there were plenty of times
um where I wanted to build my own
recruitment company my dad's an
entrepreneur and he ran his own company
and so I've always thought that one day
I would build my own recruitment company
um my twin brother lives in Australia he
runs his own recruitment company and
he's a one-man band does very well for
himself but he gets very bored and
lonely so I was really clear that it was
going to be with some people to build
something significant that could be
going going concern that at some point I
can exit gracefully from and I can look
back and be proud proud of all of those
lives that have changed all of those
careers that have moved forward all of
those people that are themselves now
becoming managers and leaders
um
so we sat down as a as as a team of
co-founders uh during 2020 and we were
thinking how could we be different like
what kind of recruitment company is
different than the other recruitment
companies
and that's really hard we talked about
AI we talked about different
technologies that we could build into
the business we talked about whether we
were going to be a search firm or you
know whatever it might be
um and then we took a look at what was
going on and in in the Years preceding
that the recruitment industry had been
evolving you you now have got embedded
recruitment businesses you've got search
firms classically you've got hybrid
businesses
um and we doubled down and thought the
most important thing is people like
people are at the center of all
companies Great companies have got great
people in recruitment is at the center
of that we are in the middle of the
scales that balance that equation
and for the foreseeable future I don't
think the machines are going to replace
people and they're going to replace how
you're made to feel
um and what kind of service levels are
memorable so we wanted to put the numi
way at the center of everything we do
which is that seven point guide that I
talked with you about previously about
how we do things to an excellent level
which is what then manifested into
raising the ball when it comes to
recruitment
so I guess the straightforward answer to
you is
we just want to do recruitment to an
absolutely excellent level
um and we're proud of that recruitment
is helping people to find jobs and it is
helping companies to build teams there's
nothing more right that that is the most
important thing we just think we do that
perfectly it's crazy right because
what you're saying sounds simple and
straightforward but where the real work
comes in is like you've already
mentioned like every single day
committing to that Excellence every
single day
committing to creating those absolute
brilliant experiences
um despite maybe getting opportunities
and moments to not do the right thing or
take that shortcut
so why don't you just add a bit more
color to give us maybe an example right
because I think people listening would
probably be curious on okay Mark that
that sounds great and I feel the same I
want to be completely committed to
delivering great experiences doubling
down on the people but maybe give us one
or two examples of like how you feel you
really create that absolute exceptional
experience on that Journey that yeah you
think clearly has been able enabled you
guys to um achieve the goals that you
set or yeah build Traction in in your
markets I think that'd be useful for
people yeah something about that is
standards and it's pretty easy to drop
your standards right especially in our
world where you can see such a quick
return you can talk to one person
introduce them to another person and
before you know it you're sending out an
invoice
and it doesn't necessarily need to be a
great deal we we think that short term
um so we've created an experience that
is partnership rather than execution and
it starts at the very beginning with
each partner that we on board we then
measure
um in a 10-point system what it is that
we're going to help them with so we
would unpack and we would look at
various Dynamics within the journey that
might be about their content or it might
be their reputation in the marketplace
or it might be their interview and
selection process and we can make a
decision whether we're going to be able
to help them on that on that journey and
we're going to be able to help them to
deliver the people that will
build their products and services and
help that company to be successful
um and in those conversations sometimes
we see some businesses that are not
prepared to commit they're not prepared
to partner they're looking for an agency
PSL they're just looking for bums on
seats and CVS and sometimes you think it
would be really easy to fill that job
and then you take a step back and you
think but what's the candidate
experience going to be like you know
you're not going to be in trouble and
control you're not going to be able to
manage you're not going to be able to
get feedback for the candidates and then
you're going to have that experience in
the marketplace that all candidates moan
about recruiters that I spoke to this
recruitment person and I didn't get any
feedback like where are you why did you
disappear on me
um so it's just maintaining those
standards it's it's just having the
strength of character to say no I can't
help you even if you think there's a
quick win in the long term that doesn't
that doesn't create a sustainable
recruitment company yeah no thank you
for sharing that I guess that let's just
go into a bit more of like the business
aspect so you've spoken about you free
guys getting together and really think
about how can we be different so we've
spoken about that what was obviously it
was free of you at the start of the
first of the business it was free of you
at the end of the first of the business
and yeah I think having sat down with a
lot of
recruitment entrepreneurs I think
sometimes people if they were being
honest uh hard too quickly
um if they were to go back and start
again a common bit of advice that we've
had on this podcast is would it just
really focus on building traction
getting money in the bank in that first
year and then sort of going from there
rather than yeah thinking about wouldn't
it be great if I could say to my mate
down the pub that there's five of us now
in our first year business you get what
I mean yeah so I guess what would be
interesting is uh why didn't you uh show
us if if if it's cool with you on what
what did the sort of go to market look
like in terms of that first year
obviously you ended up um doing really
well in that first year and what was the
plan what was the the strategy
um and I think that would be really
useful for for people and I'm sure
there'll be a ton of things that people
can learn from that
yeah I guess maybe maybe for all of
those
um entrepreneurial Minds out there that
are thinking of building their own
recruitment company
um so that might be that you're going to
build a recruitment company on your own
or you're going to build a recruitment
company with with uh one person or like
in my case with two people our journey
was really interesting uh Ricky and
Reuben were people that had worked with
me over the period of the 10 years prior
to forming numi
but in the way that we work together I
was always there Superior I was never
the guy that did deals and they were the
guys that did I mean they're a million
pound billers right they did deals for
fun and I was just the guy that shoved
around paper and made people smile and
help people develop their careers right
so that there were some really
interesting Dynamics for us that we had
to figure out first things first was
like can mark do deals can mark the
recruitment yeah it's a common thing
that people concerned about worried
about yeah I mean me too right I I
didn't know I'd done one deal in the
previous five years
I mean that was tricky right I mean I
felt like I had to earn the right and I
felt like I had to earn the right
um and both those guys you know they had
different Dynamics going on
um they hadn't built companies they
hadn't managed teams and then sat you
know board board level meetings they
hadn't gone through uh strategic work in
marketing or business Ops and all of
those things right so some of the things
in that Journey were really really
interesting for us because we look back
and reflect now and we're like
why didn't we create our racy document
earlier like why didn't we know what our
roles and accountabilities were going to
be because for a long time every
decision was three-way like you know
nibs Ricky and I all wanted to build our
marketing strategy like so every
decision within that was taking way too
long
um and it took us a long time to figure
that out and the reason was that they
were on their Journeys they wanted to
learn otherwise why the hell are they
building a recruitment company they
didn't want to just be ICS they didn't
want to just be delivery Consultants
doing recruitment you know for numi when
they may as well just be doing it for
somebody else
um so so yeah I think what what we found
was that we tried to work on the
business and in the business all at the
same time and that's really really
really hard because we've got customers
that we've committed to we've got
partners that we need to deliver to
and that's a full-time day job and then
at the same time we're like when are we
going to launch a website like Which
accounting software are you going to use
what automation are we going to build
into the business and all of those
things you're kind of working on those
thinking in the back of your mind I need
to send CVS I need 10 CVS like we need
to get some money in the bank
um I think we just worked fast
um and for those first few months we
were really at some point we we woke up
and went do you just feel like a
recruiter
yeah Ricky was like yeah like what what
are we doing
um and and then we're like okay let's
have a full strategy day and then we sat
there like you know with an agenda like
what are we doing for our marketing
strategy like which took a couple of
hours
um yeah um and and then we we realized
that actually you need to build that in
you need to be really disciplined you
need to be really really disciplined and
really organized to make sure that
you've got moments in your diary that
are working on the business
not working in the business hey everyone
a real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast partners vincere and
saucebreaker because you listen to this
podcast you were able to get your hands
on exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're all a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out Vin Cherry who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so on
that I think it'd be really useful uh
Mark if you were so because I literally
had a recent conversation with someone
that
um I've got a good relationship with
he's come on the podcast a guy called
Callum he was a bit similar to yourself
um ended up being in like a director
role was all around getting the most out
of people culture all of that recently
started his own recruitment business and
is like hell can I bill right
um and yeah quite even recently and I'm
pleased to hear that yeah like he
surprised himself and things have got to
a good start so I guess just to hone in
on that quickly because I think that
will be common for quite a lot of people
um what what would your advice be like
for someone listening who does have
aspirations start their own recruitment
business but haven't done a deal for two
years three years maybe longer maybe
doubting themselves uh what yeah where
where yeah where the uh advice be to
help someone like that to help them I
guess have a bit more confidence that
they they are still capable
I think it's not for the faint-hearted
right I think if you're building a
company you have no brand even if you've
got the most outstanding go to market
strategy nobody knows who you are
and if nobody knows who you are who's
going to give you some jobs to fill
um so you'll you need to be really great
at Business Development you need to be
really great at partnership and account
development uh relationships with the
customer with the people that pay your
bills
if your strength is delivering if your
strength is running the best goddamn
Boolean out there you know is like if
your strength is finding the best
candidates that's terrific but if you're
going to build a business if you're
going to build a community in a
Marketplace and a reputation in your in
your field and you can't win business
and you can't maintain and build
relationships with the people that pay
your bills
then don't do it so that that was one
way to answer your question so you know
for a budding recruitment entrepreneur
that's great at recruitment how do they
do deals when they haven't been doing
deals if they were a director or a
manager
get back on the tools like it's a
revelation
I think I told you didn't I I'm sat in
my kitchen day two in the pandemic when
I'm working with myself and I'm like
boom really loud and my wife comes
running in and says what what's happened
and I'm like I just some client just
messaged me and said can you fill the
job for me and I was just so happy about
it right
um I had that feeling inside of me that
buzz that you know what I can do this
um and if you don't have that buzz right
then then probably you're in the wrong
job and and probably that buzz is the
thing that Fades as well you know
recruitment people they do so many deals
that they lose at Mojo they lose that
feeling of excitement when they've done
a deal
um so yeah try it get back on the tools
see how it feels this was one of the
things that I wanted to ask you just
because you mentioned it there
um always like to ask people around the
people that I'm interviewing like
there's anything interesting that I
should ask the guests in these things
and it was one of the things that
um
Ricky said about you just because you
mentioned it so let's get into it and I
think it would be really useful this for
for people and how the Market's shifting
and the current market dynamics so Rick
said one of Mark's rule streams is
business development he has always found
a way to excel in challenging times
which is super relevant right now which
I definitely agree with I think he has
been through two or three recessions and
also covid so yeah obviously you just
touched on there getting on the tools
these things but yeah like talk to us a
bit about Mark's philosophy around yeah
still performing still winning great
Partnerships despite market conditions
despite things being really challenging
you mentioned BD there and how important
it is yeah talk to us a bit about your
philosophies around why people would
describe that Mark's always been good at
that why do you think you've always been
able to be good at that
um so I think I said earlier I you
always have to earn the right
um
one of the things that I learned when I
joined my previous recruitment firm
which was a much much larger business
than I'd than I'd had experience of
working in before
um originally for those 10 15 years I
was a big fish in a little Pond it was
kind of like all about my customers and
a bunch of people that for the large
part were filling jobs right so I spent
a long time on the customer side of
things
doing business development doing partner
account relationship and then I joined a
much larger business
um and one of the leaders in the
business not long after I joined kind of
looked at me and said yeah I've seen
your type before Big Fish Little Pond
you need to change your ways if you're
going to be successful here and that
really really hurt um
and I kind of went home and I was like
what have I done here and I was like do
you know what I actually need to earn
the right I actually need to show these
people that I can do this
um and that was a good lesson as painful
as it was it was that I have to lead
from the front I have to I have to make
it happen
um My Philosophy around business
development is that
these are just people they might be a
CEO or they might be you know some big
job title that might be intimidating if
you're young and you're in your career
but these are people that you're looking
after
um I think a good example of that was
when kovid hit
um
the world turned upside down recruited
panicked there were startled eyes
everywhere because the jobs have been
pulled from people's seats
um so my strategy was let's go back to
basics right let's fertilize the soil
before the you know the plants have
grown let's look after people
um and so I worked really really hard
probably 18 hour days in that blur of
being at home when you're not used to
being at home every day
um and I just worked so hard to look
after people so I did some things that
upon reflection now I didn't really know
what I was doing because I was in a
panic too I mean it was covid I was
going to be leaving my job and I was
going to be starting a new business so
it was like what the hell's going on
here but my strategy was to call all the
people that I'd ever interacted with and
see how they were see what advice I
could give to them I was starting
to share I was one of the first people
to start to share happy news stories on
LinkedIn so I was sharing job updates
that I wasn't even working on these jobs
and I was getting calls from other
recruiters saying why are you doing this
why are you giving this information this
is gold dust what what is your strategy
here and I was like I'm just literally
just trying my best to help people
um so yeah I think it was just that
again to to go back to consistency I was
calling people looking after them then
checking in with them calling them
looking after them checking in with them
um and as I said over the course of time
people remember how you make them feel
they remember what you did to help them
just on that just to get a bit granular
here just because I think it's the right
time to ask I'd love to just get your
thoughts would be what if I'm listening
to this and look we work with a lot of
recruiters that are on that journey to
become like 360 recruiters and these
things and that just always tends to be
a really challenging hurdle for a lot of
people to overcome and become confident
with their business development in these
things
I guess just to tie that together I'd
love to get your thoughts on like what
what do you think
um people uh recruiters have to like
really master
when it comes to business development
that you think
um will enable that person to yeah I
guess be more consistent get better at
um bringing in the clients that they
want but is there is there anything
particular that you think out of all the
skills that are required out of all the
things that you can do what what are
some of the things that you really have
to master and get absolutely excellent
at that can yeah have the knock-on
effect of enabling you to achieve your
business development goals or become
more confident with that yeah people
struggle with this they really do
um and I found that people find one
thing that they're really great at and
they continue doing that that's their
go-to default strategy
which unfortunately is usually specking
people that know me they know my
position on specking right I get it it
works and I will always hear this story
of our Specter CV and guess what we did
a deal but for what about the hundred
other specs that you did that destroyed
your reputation however there is value
in in showcasing showcasing it
exceptionally
um so I would urge and encourage people
to have a an engagement strategy which
is interesting you need to become the
interesting person in the room you need
to be the person that when the phone
rings or when the email pops up into
somebody's inbox they're like oh hey
it's Mark Mark's always got an
interesting thing to say so that might
be Market demographics it might be
reports in the industry it might be an
interesting CV it might be something to
do with a um a festival or you know a
congratulatory message about their
career or their team fundraising
something personalized but you would
have a strategy that you can go to those
people at whichever frequency is
relevant for that particular client that
you kind of develop business with but
it's six seven eight nine ten touch
points interactions consistently each
one being different and then you become
interesting and once you're that person
you're memorable and you've got your own
personality
and you don't sound like a robot and
I'll tell you what that means in a
moment but then people start to come
back to you and they don't go back to
all of the other recruitment people that
are trying to Business Development all
right now I do really like that I think
you it'd be very surprising if we were
to
ask 30 recruiters right now what is your
process to take Mark who doesn't know
about you but is a dream client of yours
and an ideal client that you believe you
can really help
to then taking them to a position where
he does know about you and he's willing
to give you 10 15 minutes to understand
how you might be able to help his
business I don't think a lot of
recruiters actually have a process on
what that is or how they're going to do
that
um and it might just look like that I
called Mark on Tuesday and I've set up a
weekly calendar reminder to call him
once a week you know so yeah it's
interesting that you uh said that and I
think that is something that more and
more recruits can incorporate in terms
of like I really like that Insight of
being interesting when
um uh doing your sort of Outreach or
trying to grasp people's attention is
like yeah be memorable will be
interesting so I do have you always had
that approach or has that just evolved
over time I mean early on one of my
first client meetings we were taking out
a bunch of contractors that we'd hired
um so I went to a bar in a pub
in Uxbridge I think
um and I was early I was nervous it was
the first time I'd hosted that kind of
thing on my own
and I was sat at the bar probably
shaking drinking beer too quickly to
build up some courage
um and the guy walked straight over to
me and said hey Mark how you doing I was
like how do you know who I who I am and
he said you'll look the same you'll
sound the same and I was like what what
are you saying and then I realized like
we had a script and my that firm at the
time we basically all said the same
things we did all the same stuff
and there was nothing unique there was
nothing interesting and I was just like
a little mini robot
um a little mini robot and that was why
I was like okay I need to be me I just
need to be unique individual I need to
be creative I just need to bring me to
the room
um just like let it all out yeah and I
love that so let's talk about so the
first the first year was all about
building traction
right
um you mentioned that around some of the
things that you sort of learn on the
more on the business the business side
what else did you um guys have to do or
maybe evolve as a as a three to I guess
grow up as business owners not just
recruiters what are some of the things
that you I guess thought about had top
of Mind implementing and going into year
two because that was clearly the year
where you yeah wanting to really grow
you had money in the bank
um yeah what were some of the other
things so you mentioned around being
really strict with making time for on
the business not always being in the
business you mentioned around rather
than always having free people make a
decision let's think about who's
responsible for what so I guess things
can happen more quickly was there
anything else that yeah was top of mind
got into year two or other things that
you did that you think then really put
you into a good steady going into
YouTube when you're then adding other
human beings on this journey and getting
people that are joining yeah free people
and an actual business not just free
recruiters that are just doing loads of
deals yeah yeah we definitely did we
didn't we certainly did didn't want to
go to market and just hire a bunch of
people that were our friends um
[Music]
so I think about eight nine months in
um Ricky and Ruben and I paid a lot of
money to uh do a four day off-site
workshop with a people and culture
consulting firm during that process they
ripped us apart which was
um which was the best thing that could
have happened at the time we thought we
had purpose values Mission Vision and a
culture deck
um and they were just words uh so what
actually happened in in those four days
were all of those words were
thematically grouped
um and they were ratified uh and checked
and we built on the back of that our
culture deck and we built on the back of
that a strong purpose that we can stick
to that actually was sort of from inside
of us
um made sense and meant that our ability
to go to market and hire people was
really clear because we had a book
basically of what it is to be a new me
where we're headed to what our values
are and so as we started to go about the
things that we were thinking how we're
going to scale this company how we're
going to grow this company so obviously
the first thing is hiring people super
hard but I know you can ask me about
that super duper hard
um but it was also about how are we
going to ensure that there's consistency
in the experience how is it going to be
that the three of us and anybody else
that works for our company
provides that same numi experience how
is that going to happen because we all
know that each recruit is different you
know some are aggressive they'll send a
CV and call the client to say I've sent
you a CV others are quite laid back
they'll email the CV they won't worry
about it they might get some feedback in
four days and those interactions those
your experiences are unique and
individual but they're not consistent
um and so those are some of the things
that we were thinking about it was how
can we create an experience and how can
we scale that
so what might be helpful with what you
did I love that you invested in that
because I think sometimes when I speak
to
um small ground recruitment companies
they can almost think doing that four
day workshop is like I will do that when
we're like 15 20 people when we're a bit
later on but as you sort of said there
what it sounds like is
that experience and then and really
being committed to it and investing what
we invested has then actually made the
next part a lot more easier because
there's just so much more clarity around
where you're going what you are what you
stand for and a lot of uh recruitment
entrepreneurs when they are small
businesses with where you're at it might
be a like couple of people don't have
that right
um and it's something that I think a lot
about because whenever I sort of um have
challenging periods or yeah I'm finding
the journey tough I found I find myself
uh uh sort of detached from the wire
from where we're growing from what yeah
what the the clarity around yeah why the
hell we're doing what we're doing and I
think when you if you don't even have
that it must be so hard I mean so for
sure right yeah in in our experience we
had three different people and we need
to we needed to make sure that we were
aligned we knew there are going to be
times that are tough right and we needed
to make sure that we saw the world the
same way that our wives our families all
under stand what is the reason that
we're building numi why is Mark working
on a Sunday what Dad what are you doing
you're Your Own Boss and I think a lot
of recruitment
um owners well a lot some recruitment
people they they want to build a
lifestyle business they just want to
build a business so it's okay if they
pop out on Friday afternoon play golf or
you know manage their time however they
will
um but we were really clear that that
wasn't what we were going to be doing we
wanted to build a business that was
significant that we could reinvest back
into the business it's going to take us
some years but at Point there'll be an
exit and so we needed to be sure that
during tough times we had a strong
purpose and a strong why
and actually this is really important
for us when we're hiring
um both for numi but also when we're
hiring for our customers and when we're
talking with candidates and and I don't
know if this is the way the world is
evolving but it feels like it used to be
about money and it doesn't it it's not
like that anymore
um I think there's you know more modern
generation of people they need to see
purpose people understand the meaning
and the value of purpose like they have
choices they have flexibilities they
have hybrid approaches to to the way
that they want to run their lives and if
a prospective employer doesn't have a
strong purpose they're not gonna they're
not gonna talk to them right and we
don't want to just pay people more than
the next person yeah no it's so powerful
and I was just going to ask you was
what what were uh what sort of if I was
to say to you what were maybe because it
all for me from my experience it's all
about obviously you've got people that
experts facilitating these days and I'm
sure so much goes into it but for me
it's all about the quality of questions
that you sort of ask yourself and you do
really have to dig deep and think about
them in these things but I think for
people listening that yeah may not have
the money to do a full day off-site but
for you from that experience and clearly
it's been massively impactful what would
you say are like I don't know maybe one
two three absolute crucial questions
that people need to think about if they
do want to grow a business a significant
business or they do um yeah wanna yeah
have more clarity on their purpose was
there any sort of questions that stood
out to you or do you think important
questions that people should definitely
mull overthink about and have a clear
answer to
I think you should be clear on
what are you leaving
are you leaving because you're trying to
move away from something or are you
leaning into and moving towards
something
and some people don't really understand
that that question is so important
that's vital you might be in a great job
you might be in the job in a company
where you don't enjoy the environment or
the culture you might be looking at the
revenues in that business and thinking
why I'm only getting X percent of those
revenues my commission plan isn't as
strong as it could be the leadership at
the board are taking all of this money
and they're not really giving me that
back and I'd like a slice of that pie
so I think before you get into this you
need to think about what you're actually
doing currently and what the again to
sort of keep on that purpose and Mission
thing but
building a recruitment company isn't
very easy at all like doing deals might
be easy short term it might be easy but
long-term building a recruitment company
is not very easy at all which is why a
lot of people don't do it
um and so probably take a good hard look
at yourself and think am I running away
from something or am I leaning into
something like that so that's that's
probably the fundamental one to be fair
yeah I think so so if you answer that
though and I'm I don't know let's just
say like you guys a year in two years in
I might have a couple of recruiters
these things and yeah because I speak to
a lot of people that that want to scale
but find it extremely difficult and I
think it's these types of things that
can massively help if you have Clarity
on where you're going what you're doing
is there any question that stood out to
you when you did that four day workshop
that I don't know really got you guys
thinking or are there any sort of really
fundamental uh good quality questions
that business owners need to have an
answer to do you think
do you know one of the questions that we
couldn't answer was
the the consulting firm that we were
working with
like this time next year what are your
job titles going to be
and we're like we just don't look to
each other
I don't know you want to be CEO what do
you want to be
and we don't really have a clear answer
to that now we're now clearer on the
accountabilities that we each occupy
um but yeah that was hard
um
yeah I don't know what else to say no
yeah fair enough yeah I think maybe yeah
I'll just I was just curious to find out
if there's any questions that stood out
I guess so couple last
um things then let's talk about the
hiring piece because that is a real pain
for a lot of uh recruitments that I I
speak to what what's been your your
journey with that obviously you did this
upfront work before you got to the point
of speaking to other people to come on
the journey so clearly that's had a real
positive impact but what yeah what
what's been really difficult so far in
this last 12 months or so in hiring
people for your own recruitment business
well we thought we'd done an Immaculate
piece of work with our strategy
um
we built some
uh documents uh we we each agreed what
our Outreach strategy was going to be
um so there's three people running a
business doing deals looking after our
partners
um
and on top of that we then need to start
hiring people
um
you have to remember the time right it
was about a year into the best year in
most recruitment people's lives
everybody was getting it like everybody
were earning big bonuses and we were
going for experienced recruitment people
um that we knew could come in adopt a
new way and hit the ground running so we
were going into a Marketplace that was
really challenging
um hey look at numi and people like who
are you
um why would I leave I'm killing it
um and so their their response rates
were really low when we actually talked
to people they were interested but they
would quite often say to us this is
really interesting I'm gonna watch you
but I'm not ready to leave now because
I'm waiting for this massive bonus
um or you're a startup and I want to go
to a more established company or you're
a small company and I want to work for a
business that's got offices everywhere
um
so I I think we had to sort of rework
and think about what is actually going
on here and how much time are we
spending
um we didn't really have many more hours
in the day when we break it down now we
were probably spending three or four
hours a week doing recruitment to get
people to come and work for us and
um that just wasn't enough
um we cracked it a little bit we hired a
few people but I think what happened was
after about six months we doubled down
and thought
if we're going to be serious about this
we need to employ somebody that's going
to do this for us an expert which sounds
crazy right because we're a group of
people why can't we recruit for
ourselves
but it's a full-time job yeah it is a
full-time job it's about content it's
about engagement it's about you know
your interview process it's around
standing out it's around answering why
is your company different than all the
other recruitment companies out there
that are hiring
um and so that was the decision that we
made second half of last year um was to
employ an internal Talent acquisition
professional to to build our company for
us and how how how's that going
I think it's great so far yeah um we we
offered two people this week
um so so that's good um but early days
right
um we have we've we've now got a head of
operations head of talent they've been
with us less than three months and what
they're doing is the engine underneath
the Bonnet that everything that makes
the car go faster
I think that just shows a real
commitment to where you're going
um or the clarity that you have and
where you're going because I think
if you think about it I'd be very
interested to know how many other
recruitment businesses
at the size of what there would have
been what three four like five of you
maybe before you made those highs of
making an internal recruiter hire or a
do you know what I mean I think that
that says a lot because you have the
clouds and where you want to go
and you recognize okay this is bloody
difficult on top of everything else like
that makes more sense that's why I think
the a big sort of insight I've learned
from here is is that commitment to know
where you're going doing the work these
things because I'm sure you guys comes
that decision more quickly because you
knew like if we get this person it works
we're gonna get to where we want to
hopefully quicker or yeah even in a
better way because we can have an expert
just doing this every single day but I'd
love to know how many other recruitment
companies made that internal recruiter
high at that sort of similar period to
you guys you know what I mean
I mean it's a big decision right you're
so so you go from
set setting up your own company um
winning some business sending some
invoices all good
then you employ people and you
definitely want to employ people that
are also going to bring in business
right they're also going to bring in
some revenues
very different by the way being a
manager of people
that you employ yourself is very
different to being employed and being a
manager and then that next decision
am I going to employ people that at
surface level are not going to bring
anything in terms of Revenue to the
company and so you start to look at
those salaries as a cost
so those salaries that operations that
Talent person their salaries are the
same as the license for LinkedIn they're
the same as the license for your
accounting software they're the same as
the cost of working in an office
and that's the decision right that's
um the difference that we've chose to
make is we're now hiring people that are
going to help with efficiencies and help
with growing the business rather than
just hiring people that are going to
bring in Revenue
so talk to me as we finish then 2023
what what's on the
The Horizon for you guys then how like
talk to us a bit about where yeah if we
were to sit down in another two years
time where would you love me to be
uh so I think we're lucky in that
um in the uh we we will expand
internationally
um the reason that I know we'll do that
is because Ricky wants to move to
another country
uh so we have the Americas on our
journey
um I think the most important thing that
we can get right in 2023 is our Learning
and Development program from the people
that we'll be hiring
um which is why we're talking to you
um but also some leadership coaches uh
non-execs so we're really going to
double down on the career development
Frameworks and the leveling guides and
our ability to help people to have a
sustainable career and be proud of the
work that they do and to be continuously
learning
um we have some ideas around
um the work that we're doing and what
we're going to call the planet practice
um so this is our society for giving
back
um we have some Journeys to take around
Corporate social responsibility Edie and
I
um we've already signed up ecology and
clean Hub to make sure that the work
that we do is also helping Mother Earth
um we're gonna and well we're
considering going B core but we're not
sure how much value that would add
um but certainly we think that in the
work that we can do we can help people
find jobs we can move people forward in
their careers and while we're doing that
we can do some work that's sustainable
in in the planet that's really cool it's
a cool thing about having a business
isn't it though and you get into those
things yeah I mean we we kind of think
that we can build some practices and
each practice can have an aligned
charity and then those different
practices can look at the value that
they're giving back and and you know you
can have competitions around Billings
but if you had competitions around how
much your team is giving back for the
work that you're doing we think that's
awesome that's really cool yeah well
look Mark absolute pleasure I know
there's just so many different things we
can go into right with your journey but
um I just yeah I love and I've mentioned
it a few times but just yeah love
um how engaged and passionate are about
the the journey that you're on
um like it's yeah no easy feat doing any
job for such a long period of time but
then to have like just renewed
motivation perspective on right we're
now going to build this great business
we're going to take people on this
journey I'm um yeah really excited to
see where you guys end up and yeah no
doubt it's going to be in a great place
and you're gonna do some great things
along the way so massive thank you for
joining me on the Pod thanks for having
me man it's been really good fun thank
you so much for listening to the episode
I hope you enjoyed it and got value from
the conversation if you did enjoy it
please don't forget to like share and
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
episode